hey everyone
thanks for joining my name stephanie
wong customer engineer here at google
and we have here of course you know
jonathan cham and welcome to gcp online
meetup number
38 38 yes
so we're super excited today because we
have
addison howard over here from kaggle and
he is a program manager so he's going to
be talking about everything he knows
about kaggle the community
involved in it so we're super excited
learning as well so i'm gonna let him
take it away and introduce himself
yes addison are you alive i am alive
yeah it's alive and well live from
denver colorado
um so glad to be a part of this i'm
really excited uh i
like said my name is addison howard i'm
a program manager uh on kaggle
uh calgary's been a part of google now
for about six months we're the home for
data science
and uh super comfortable to be a part of
this yeah thanks addison
so i mean i don't know stephanie when
the topic came up will they take our
jobs i was a little concerned because i
don't know do you think
our jobs will be lost i don't know i
feel like i'd be pretty okay with having
half my job be covered by
automated service i mean i could put my
feet up that's true work part-time yeah
part-time sounds pretty good sounds
pretty good but i think i mean
in all seriousness i think the topic of
you know automation and labor and the
economy and ai and ml like how all these
things fit together
and the impact of it is a serious
concern and i mean even politicians are
talking about it right now so i thought
it was a good topic to bring up
and i know addison he's been dealing
with a lot of you know competitions
a lot of work with large companies and
small companies around you know
predictions automations and i'm you know
i'm guessing
if anybody knows the answer to this
addison probably has
at least the best idea about what he
sees you know
in the future yeah well we'll see
because i would say
the answer the question of will machine
learning take your job is kind of a big
fat maybe
um i mean when it comes to future work
though almost
one in every two jobs do have a high
risk of being automated by machines
now when you say that right i always
think like terminator or something like
that but
but no it's things that can be automated
and repeated
over and over again but on the flip side
machines cannot do things that require a
novel approach
or are based on something that they
haven't seen many many times before so
well when you think about it um i always
kind of find it fascinating that the
term data science itself didn't even
exist until like 2008
um so i mean it was gosh i was a
junior in college at the time and data
science finally came around as a term
and it's really accelerated the past few
years but you've already seen it in some
common things in the world right so
um think about um mail snail mail
back to somebody's job was to look at
every single letter and say well i think
that's a one thing that's a seven and
divide it up
well now they have out machine learning
algorithms that will scan handwritten
numbers and sort them
so that's an example of something um but
now you take that to a newer extent and
you're seeing machines that can read
retina scans of eyes and while one one
ophthalmologist may look at a scan of an
eye
maybe 50 000 scans of the course of
their career we are now training
machines who will do the same thing
in a matter of hours and so overall
um i will say it kind of depends but
ultimately uh always be reminded that
machines cannot do things that require a
novel approach
or based on something that they haven't
really seen many times before
yeah maybe the different way to look at
it is that machines aren't necessarily
replacing your jobs
i mean they might be replacing portions
of your job but it might be actually
saving you time
so that you can be doing more
interesting work instead of manual
exactly exactly in the example of
medicine right
we're now freeing up the time that many
ophthalmologists have
from looking at scans over and over
again to now being able to
do more research and do more um ground
groundbreaking
things in the in the world yeah so i see
with my customers that i mean that's
exactly right like taking over
like the entire job or entire role is
pretty rare
it's more about helping to really help
helping
workers be more productive so you know
i mean we still need mailmen but instead
of looking at numbers and trying to
figure out what zip code it is
you know they're you know actually
putting mail inside of your mailbox
right
right right or or they're looking at
other ways to be more efficient with
their shipping and routes and things
like that
right cool that's yeah so that's i mean
i guess that's the
net of the answer i'd love to hear from
the audience you know what your thoughts
are
on you know you know have you seen an
impact yourself
what are your thoughts are in terms of
uh you know the impact on the economy
i'd love to hear
what you guys think um but i mean yeah
addison i know you had a couple other
things you wanted to go through
like how i mean what you know what does
kaggle do and how
has it impacted at the industry as a
whole because i feel like it has
sure so through kaggle um kyle is known
as the home of data science
kind of the the fun fact is the term
kaggle is literally just a
amalgamation afraid of sounds that
didn't have a domain name taken yet
and uh and that's how kaggle came to be
uh there's some uh some fun
internal team folklore around what the
other alternatives would have been
um but uh it's basically become the home
of data science
originally we kind of came in the market
about six or seven years ago
running machine learning competitions
where um
our ceo anthony goldblum wanted to
predict the results of eurovision
if you're familiar with eurovision kind
of the big american idol style
competition through everywhere every
country in europe submits a
uh or sends a um representative and sort
of some like alliances and things like
that that occur
well they want to host a competition to
do that and that quickly expanded to
people coming to kaggle to learn how to
do data science again data science
hasn't been around for
really much more than a decade and a lot
of people who are currently in
the um usually the engineering community
maybe computer science community
uh maybe mathematical community are
wanting to get involved in this
and there is a whole lot of research out
there there wasn't at the time
and like many of us can likely relate to
one of the best ways to learn is
to go figure it out and try it out and
so um
through competitions what end up
happening is for people interested
in data science on the community side
people will come and have a really
unique problem they can then go test
their
test their knowledge on i'm trying to
predict x i'm trying to
guess why we'll go through a couple of
those here in a bit um on the business
side of the house what we're seeing is
a lot of companies they don't have a big
data science group yet
maybe they have one or two folks maybe
they don't have some maybe they do have
a couple dozen people who are data
scientists and
they're saying we've been trying to
solve a couple problems but we need some
additional help
we need to then throw it over to a
community and kaggle now has
uh do you think we just surpassed our
1.3 million people
in our community who have come to kaggle
saying we want to do we want to do more
we want to learn more
and since competitions we've now started
adding in things like data sets and
kernels uh data sets being you know you
always hear about 80 of the work is just
cleaning up and munching data together
this now provides a wide variety of data
for people to look at and play around
with and analyze
and then kernels which we can get to
later as well as a bit of a code sharing
platform
yeah i think one of the daunting things
about it is trying to do something by
yourself especially when it comes to
data science
if you have little to no experience so
just having that community
forum and people to uh validate your
creations with is something
that you know we haven't really seen in
the industry
past you know like you said a decade
before even just the past few years
so yeah so outside of the obvious reason
why a company or organization would use
kaggle an obvious reason would be like
hey i want to hedge my bet on you know
instead of hiring a bunch of ml data
scientists
i want to see if this is even plausible
or feasible
let me put out an award like ten
thousand dollars
see what the results look like i mean i
feel like that's the main reason why
people use kaggle are there any other
reasons
outside of that that a kaggle would be
useful for
for for an organization yeah so i think
um
two two come to mind one is i'd say
fresh perspective
so for example one competition that
we're currently running is zillow
uh it's a zillow competition if you're
familiar with zillow they have the
zestimate
and um and some people kind of maybe
complain saying oh well
that's not how much my house is worth
definitely wrong for my house
and zillow's saying like yeah we know we
get it right we understand it's not
always correct
but and we want to do better and so they
have a team of data scientists that have
been working on this algorithm
and working on it and there's some
things that are more technical around
like overfitting or
tweaking the same thing until the point
where it doesn't become very useful
anymore
they said we have a big team let's but
let's get some fresh eyes on this and
see
is there more meat left on the bone to
get some value out of what this
algorithm we're creating
which i think that's one common area and
a second area is novel approaches
for those who are familiar with machine
learning there's sort of been different
trends across the industry around what
techniques are useful
so one you know a big popular one in the
beginning is called random forest
but there's other ones that come up
throughout the um throughout the years
that kai was kind of been the um the
place where those have been
elevated and so like one of the really
big common ones now is called xgboost
yeah i was just gonna mention that i
don't know what it is but i hear it
everywhere
exactly well and that's something that
has really kind of come to the forefront
as being
something that's useful through kaggle
because like you mentioned
it's such a big community instead of it
just being somebody holding on to their
their methodology they'll still win the
competition and they'll say hey guys
here's what i did um data scientists
here's my methodology
i tried this new technique why don't you
guys play around with it and see what
you can do with it as well
what has the community generally looked
at from what you've seen in terms
of how teams are formed and people that
are really interested in getting
involved in contests
are they students other professionals
yeah it's kind of a mix of both
um one cool thing that we've we've
recently released is
actually is actually a university-style
platform like university method where
a lot of teachers are saying we could
really teach data science well
in our classroom with the competition
type format and so we have something
called
in class that is pretty much just for
students to have that type of
that learning ground but on the same
side
it's really a wide variety of people
from all types of backgrounds becoming
part of kaggle
and so what we see is as competitions
start um people start we have discussion
forums are very very prevalent for us
and
people start flooding them with hey i
found these three articles that might be
helpful
um hey i have i'm this is my my
professional educational background
anybody want to be on my team
and literally see people saying sure
message me i'm uh i'm in germany
i'm in bangladesh i'm in hawaii let's
create a team together
and it's cool to see just people who've
never met each other in
in person and sometimes as they will win
the competition i'll introduce them to
one of these clients
they're meeting for the first time via
video call
because they're just saying hey i'm here
to learn and i want to learn from
anybody no matter where they are
um skill wise or geographically
yeah i know people you know some
companies using it as a recruiting
platform actually
so yeah yeah yeah yeah
um yeah it's it's actually pretty neat
we've i mean a lot of big players have
you have
i say big players because a couple of
them um
there were pre-acquisition maybe there
might be some brands that um
uh would be rivals to us but no so you
can look at our website you see
walmart's and facebook's in all states
that come to us on a
very regular basis saying this is a
great way for us to
have a um almost like an accelerated job
interview
you know instead of instead of putting
them in a room they can do a quick
hackathon
let's give them three months to go
figure out what they can go do and give
them a problem similar to what they
would do on a regular basis
that can attract people who are
interested and um and give them like a
day in the life
well um i actually have a question from
online
um do you know how community engagement
is encouraged i mean besides just
organically how people
you know comment and want to be involved
in a project but are there other
interesting ways that you've tried to
encourage
different community topics to be
discussed or people to
start voting on different solutions that
people yeah
yeah so i i will say a majority of it is
organic um
and there's actually it's for some
people they're incentivized by we
actually have rankings
so we have rankings today how good of a
competitor are you
how good of a kernel author code-sharing
person are you
and how good of a discussion personally
you can get different rates based off of
expert master grand master you know we
have occasional private competitions
just for our masters and grand masters
and i think a lot of is that people
people just genuinely come to learn and
people generally come to
hey i can share if i share my knowledge
here
um then somebody else can even clean off
that and expand upon it um and so
we've occasionally actually offered some
prizes for best kernels
best new data sets to continue that
engagement um but
i've been very surprised and very
pleased at really how
organic that has been as it is you were
telling us earlier about the twitter
conversations that you have right now
about machine learning
yeah talk about that a little bit
because yeah
this that's been pretty neat is um and
we do have a full
a full team of ours at kaggle is just a
community team that's looking for ways
to continue to get people involved
both inside competitions which again
what we kind of
have been known for historically but now
as we've expanded to become truly a
broader home for data science
and so the past three uh past three
weeks we've and we have one coming up
next week
i'm actually not sure how many more we
have after that going into the holidays
but we've been hosting
debates on twitter um that have been
posing a certain problem or question
within
um data science and saying let's talk
about this and so the very
the very first one we had was with um
actually a guy that
used to be a kaggle grand master
discussion
expert and then he came over we
basically uh poached him from our own
community
and brought him on board and he was
answering the question okay ai
what's the hype where's the overhyped
where's it under hyped what can it
really accomplish
um last week we had one with another one
of our community members talking about
biased and biased machine learning
um one example here for those not
familiar with that would be if i were to
create an algorithm
that's trying to take pictures of stock
photo pictures of people in professions
and say okay is this
a doctor or a lawyer but if every
picture of a doctor that i bring in
there is an old white guy
and all of a sudden algorithms only
think that doctors are all old white
guys
and so there's a there's a lot of
questions around bias that's that's been
um recurring
and one that just happened last night um
with one of our community leads was
which is more important the algorithm of
the data you know it's how
is having a good a good algorithm but
bad data or vice versa
going to get you better or worse results
and kind of talking through that so
we've been hosting those
every tuesday um you can follow the
hashtag hashtag ml debate i believe is
what it is
you can check out our twitter account
see that as well cool yeah i've actually
it's
i forgot what podcast but i was
listening to something about how
sometimes ml can perpetuate negative
stereotypes because of that
right and sometimes it's very
controversial
so it's right it's just really
interesting how
kind of well and kind of lab around that
what's interesting about those problems
is
sometimes you just don't have you don't
have the capability to
get all data that you want especially
when you're starting working with human
individual
with humans it's hard to get a very true
representative sample
so we need to often be conscious that
machine learning
isn't always designed to be the perfect
solution but maybe creating an algorithm
is to go from step
zero to eight and then maybe take the
rest of it getting from eight to ten
yeah so we do have a question from the
chat can you cover how someone with no
ml experience could use kaggle
i'll answer that from my perspective and
addison maybe i'll let you answer
maybe stephanie um but like so i
actually had no ml experience
when when google acquired kaggle so i
went to
first of all what is kaggle and then i
noticed that okay it's a bunch of
competitions of something and then
um but then i got really interested in
like basically
there's a problem statement and you have
to solve it right
so what i did was i went into these
competitions i started looking at all
these things called kernels which are
kind of like open notebooks that people
write in to
develop some kind of algorithm or
software to help
basically take the data set that's
provided by the customer and do some you
know manipulation modeling and training
on it
and the ability to look through
basically hundreds of people's notebooks
and look at how they
you know take a perspective on the
problem that's how i learned about ml
i'm definitely not the expert still but
i mean it was just a wealth of knowledge
sitting in all these you know uh
jupiter notebooks so maybe i'll have i
don't know stephanie and then i'll let
madison answer that yeah i know i agree
with that i mean i think
i'm also getting started with learning
much more about machine learning and
how to leverage a lot of the tools that
people are using and being able to see
and learn from example is key as you
said because it's just
difficult to start with nothing and i
don't even know where to get started
sometimes a lot of it can go over your
head
so having those example data sets and
what people have thought of out of the
box is
just incredibly helpful and i'm sure
addison will yeah
and just one more note like the
top-rated kernels usually have
very very very good documentation
meaning that the person took the time to
write out exactly
what that person did and why and so i
mean just reading all of that is a good
learning experience as well there's a
lot of comments a lot of community
engagements
which is why i mean i think capital is a
great place to learn ml so if you don't
know
well actually capital is the place to go
yeah and awesome at ml it's also the
place to go
yeah i i think you're right and you said
it well is that it i think it provides a
lot of opportunities based on
whatever level you're at um i will say
it's just to play a little bit devil's
advocate against myself
um if if you're coming in and so like i
don't have a i don't have a
computer developer background at all i'm
more of a more of a business guy and so
i have experience in math econ that sort
of
side of the house so i'm starting right
now i'm teaching myself python
so i'm getting out of that level um but
a lot of times you may say
okay i have this i have this technical
skills i have nowhere to apply to test
it
we have a couple of different
introductory competitions as one way of
doing that
uh for example one of the most the most
popular competition we've ever held is
one on the titanic
where we said basically is this person
going to survive or not and you give
them a whole list
and so you can think just on an
intuitive level or what if you just said
men don't survive women and children do
you probably get 80
right and then you start toggling things
like okay what if they were wealthy what
if they weren't what if they're in the
top part of the ship where they weren't
it sort of gives you opportunity to play
around with that and a very free
a free low low ego low risk environment
right
and we start having some more advanced
things that okay can you predict
um housing prices in a nonzillow sort of
way
uh can you can you if you want to get
more into image recognition we have
competitions for that that are
introductory so
that's one of the best ways as jonathan
mentioned kernels i think it's great as
well
kernels for us um it's not just code
sharing but
what we would like to do is take out a
lot of the dependencies
so if someone were to share you their
code else or otherwise it may be okay go
download
all 16 of these different libraries and
versions and things like that
we try to remove a lot of that to keep
sharing pretty easy um
and then thirdly we we're continuing to
develop out
more tried and true educational
curriculum to have a team that is
based on that is entirely rooted in
creating
education-based documentation that we
hope to be releasing here soon
that's that's really cool so i know we
have about 10 minutes left and we'll
leave some room for q a do you mind just
taking
a couple minutes to walk through the
user interface i mean i know i feel like
people who have never looked or used
kaggle maybe you can show them where the
kernels are where the competitions are
yeah yeah let me um let me go ahead and
share my screen here
um go back to where it was
cheers
yeah so while you do that i mean
stephanie how have you used kaggle so
far
so i actually use it to try and find
public data sets that people have
already offered or that were already
natively on the site just so that i can
have some sort of
way of testing out my own creations and
i've actually used it
on a workshop as well just to see what
we have available online
so i've already found it pretty useful
and i get email notifications of
different contests that are being
offered by
other commercial um you know companies
that are offering contests and prizes so
i do often see some really interesting
use cases for example the zillow one
there's one for holiday gift exchanging
and how you can predict
how someone could get the right gift
that they've wanted so yeah
you'll never get the right one yeah some
of them are fun yeah
yeah it's been really great for us um
now being a part of uh being a part of
the google team for like i said it's
been closed about nine months now
actually
um we had the chance to be a lot to have
a little bit more fun with uh
competitions and
provide some more unique unique items
there as well but um
logging into kaggle if you're already
logged in this is the page you'll see um
actually let me see here i think i have
the other one
uh pulled up um as well so if you're not
logged in
uh can you if you're seeing this new
page or okay you get more of this what
is kaggle and you get things like
i'm maybe in a job or some very high
level
elements but okay how can i learn to do
data science and talking about
um exactly the same things we were just
mentioning surviving the titanic
they want to study some benchmark models
that already exist we have plenty of
blogs as well so
we we interview previous winners so for
example this data science bowl was
around heart disease and we interviewed
winners and said what did you do to win
we can kind of talk through that and so
there's a wide variety of ways things
here
that you can see always like to mention
playing with data
you'll see that before you log in but
once you log in
you sort of have a dashboard and this is
going to be you know
just like a standard news feed based off
the things you respond to and what
you're a part of
and then up here is where pretty much
people spend motion time in these these
five primarily these three
um competitions like i mentioned before
um we'll have a list of
all the active competitions that we have
by prize um
so we have one for passenger screening
algorithm this is with tsa in the
department of homeland security
wow you remember you know you're talking
about going going to the airport and
putting your hands up and spinning
around on the machine
well we took 3d images or not now we dhs
that took 3d images of users
and basically strapped different objects
to their body and said
all right is there an item on this
person's lower right thigh
yes or no and what is the likelihood
that there is yes or no
um and so there's a wide variety of
competitions that can really be
um interesting entirely depending on
what your
interest is both off of skill set are
you interested more in image-based data
3d imaging text
audio tabular data industry
so you can see here we have things like
security
real estate this is mercari is i know
expanding a lot in the u.s right now
they're kind of like a um
an offer up or a craigslist style app um
uh we have one that's image basis
literally uh satellites from the space
saying
there's a picture of a ship or an
iceberg that way as ships are planning
their navigation routes they can try to
better plan how to get to certain
locations really a whole slew of
different things
recruit is a is a japanese company that
is um
similar to in the us that we have like a
groupon as well as an open table kind of
both kind of both of those
and they're saying what's the likelihood
that someone's going to go to a
restaurant today or not
um and as you mentioned a couple of fun
ones so we have this
spooky author identification that said
based off of people's writing styles can
you guess who wrote it
now obviously this is one that's a
little bit more for uh more for fun
yeah you could just go google those
things but um
people are putting money behind it
though i mean it seems like like
someone's funding this fun idea
so so this one this one actually we
funded we created this one as a plugin
competition
um and so we don't have an exact quote
winner on this one because you could
just search
and put in all the actual answers right
but we have prizes of
um top upvoted awards for um best
kernels uh
best themes on tutorials discussions so
there are other ways like i mentioned
earlier trying to get people involved in
that
um and like you mentioned we just
launched a competition yesterday
on uh we've always called the santa
challenge with the santa challenge every
year
it's more of a fun one the one this year
is a little bit less machine learning
and it's more of an optimization type of
challenge
but it's always a good time for us as
you mentioned data sets
is a pretty common way we're actually
seeing a lot more people come to kaggle
saying oh i know you guys are a dataset
platform i never heard your competitions
which is really cool for us as we grow
and um it's both
our team going out and finding as you
see here we have over 6 000 data sets
um that actually what do you have here
with them for the most votes
um different um okay credit we have
everything from credit card for all
detection
uh this is a pretty common one that a
lot of people like to uh to use is
a wide variety of clean data on movies
so the idea is that it not only provides
you with clean data
it provides a community with the
opportunity to kind of see what other
people are doing
um as well as uh just gives you an area
to play around with things you're
interested in
i think i saw yeah here's one that's
european soccer if it's one that's on
pokemon
uh there's one on wine ratings uh
there's pokemon
right down there so um it gives people a
chance to
do some exploratory type data analysis
on their own
without um without any kind of
or just more of a um of a um
an introductory way to kind of play
around with stuff because maybe you
don't have the data to play around with
it or you're saying
hey i don't have the um the bureau of
labor statistics information for
bulgaria for 1938
in an easily organized fashion oh wait
but kaggle does
because somebody else is just as
passionate about it as i am and they
uploaded it
there's a lot of cool opportunities
there as well yeah i think that's
powerful because i you know
traditionally you don't have that amount
of
available data sets for you to actually
test your knowledge improve your skill
set
you know just sharpen your talent in
those areas and also just build off a
community that's able to
improve maybe what you did and you
didn't think about it right
yeah right we're starting to see a lot
of a lot of um companies too because as
you mentioned
we don't host competitions that have
public data because then we can just go
look it up and and win the competition
we have a lot of people saying we have
data we wanted to make public so people
can go do things with it
a lot of companies that truly do see the
value of publicly available data for
broader analysis and we're getting a lot
of that being brought in
um to our community as well um
and that's very briefly on kernels i
think we kind of mentioned this as well
but this is
a big opportunity to share your own work
and so
as i mentioned the biggest value people
see is sort of two-fold one
sharing and two is not having to deal
with
downloading a wide variety of libraries
and versions and languages and things
like that
what's very common is what we call
forking kernels
and so somebody might have a particular
script or notebook that they want
that they have but it's most want to use
it for a different a different
um use case so an example may be
somebody has a mcdonald's use case
and somebody else has a and they did a
twitter sentiment analysis on mcdonald's
and female says this is a great code
that i want to use i want to apply it to
united airlines
and they then go and then do that with
united airlines they can then copy and
paste
or rather be called forking and then
basically just tweak that part of the
code that
they need to to shift that new data and
you can see here i mean some of these
have you know hundreds of comments that
are people talking about
talking about it this top one is a
recently
um exciting you know it's been updated
in the past two hours
uh see if we can get this loaded here
with the past the last few minutes we
got
uh as you mentioned jonathan it's gonna
be all it's very very
um um well documented so you see things
like
i go you know people speaking in more of
a common language
all different types of uh visualizations
uh you usually even see some some fun
animations sometimes people will bring
in there as well so
it gives people a chance to really learn
and grow from whatever stage of
development that you're currently in
with machine learning cool
awesome well i think that's almost all
the time we have
um is there any other questions from
online um
no i mean yeah there are some i guess i
kind of answered it
on your behalf but one of the questions
was
it seems like kaggle's primary purpose
is to help businesses crowdsource
solutions to a data science problem
is that a big problem that businesses
have now and my responsibilities
i mean at least from a customer
perspective because i work with
customers every day
you know hiring ml and data scientists
is really hard especially
specifically for industry experts right
it's just not possible
we're actually we're probably taking all
of them if possible yeah so
i don't know yeah what is your response
to that i i think you said it well i
think what we're seeing a lot is people
usually understand ml in one of three
ways either
i hear about this i know i should do i
have no way no idea where to get started
i i hear about it and and i know i need
to or rather i guess the first one is
why should i be involved with ml second
i know i need to be involved with ml i
don't know how to get started and two is
i know i don't need to be involved with
it i know how to get started now let's
go use kaggle for it
and so and so i interact with people on
all three of those different sides um
i i think for those of us who are maybe
in that developer community it's easy to
think
what do you mean people don't under
don't get this it's like if you've no
idea how many times i have to explain to
my own parents what kaggle is and they
still don't know what it is or machine
learning to be
at the least so it is growing so rapidly
that we don't think we have no idea
where the saturation point really is
even going to begin
well addison thank you so much for your
time um i guess for now we still have
our jobs
for now i thought i was going to get it
for now we can't go home early today
on episode 39 brought to you by machine
learning generated host
uh don't say that addison no this is the
fun part of our job
okay yeah exactly anyway well thank you
so much for uh what tuning in
and thank you for chatting hit subscribe
if you enjoyed this
show if you didn't hit subscribe anyway
uh
and we'll see you next time thank you
thank you